all
right let me know if we're live guys let
me know if we're live one in the chat
one in the chat if Pearl is live okay um
to start the
show I
need blessing one blessing did not go on
a strike guys I need you to stop
roasting blessing in the
chat this is enough this is do you want
something do you want to say something
I'm
yeah now now you're on
strike oh my God see what you guys did
this is so crazy so crazy
okay so up blate blessing my forehead's
cut off in the video can you fix
it see no come back see what you guys
did all right one in the chat if you can
hear me
okay oh now he's
back okay so today
guys there was a really interesting
conversation going on on Twitter okay
let me let me pull this up over
here
um and what I wanted to ask the question
today is the conversation between
tradcons and conservatives or sorry and
the red pill now a lot of you guys don't
even really know what the red pill is I
think there's a lot of misconceptions
about what it
is
now I'm going to give you my best
interpretation of what it is red pill
really started as pickup so guys were
trying to figure out how to get laid and
what they did was they exchange notes
that's when you have the mystery
guy and they said oh you know I think
there's like peacocking I'm not an
expert in pickup so please do not come
to me for that advice I can't tell you
how to get chicks not my thing all right
but basically the guys came together and
they found out like I think one thing he
said was you know peacocking so if a guy
wears a funny outfit women come up to
him and so they all took
notes and that and that's what they said
all right so red pill evolved okay men
were having problems in their marriage
so they would say I'm having this issue
with my wife what can I do about it then
they try to fix it all right I'm having
this issue with my girlfriend oh I've
noticed
that women tend to find God around the
age of 28 to 32 these chicks that have
never been in a church in their
life all of the sudden find
God now
are there genuine
conversions
yes but the men really got together and
said this is real convenient
timing this is so crazy like you guys
didn't find God at 12 years old you
didn't find God at 16 years
old but all around the age of
28 convenient timing
okay so oh my gosh did I lose my okay so
you
know I never understood why you can't
make a general
observation without getting attacked
about the
church so I recently um I recently had a
tweet and this tweet
said let me pull it up to double check
because people were mad about this
people were very upset pearls just doing
her
thing now before I talk about this I
want to give you my credentials because
everybody says Pearl you're not a real
Christian okay and the standards for
Christians it just really depends on who
you talk to I guess if I was an ex porn
sorry corn star but I said sorry after
then I could be a real one but right now
I I don't know you know apparently okay
so I I don't know every time I
say you know I I feel like I have to
give an explanation I have to give you
my my detailed religious history okay I
did 12 Years Catholic School 12 years I
had never been to a public school until
I came to England I know privilege right
okay am I real am I fake I don't know I
don't know I did two years of Bible
study in in a Protestant church I went
to Bible study once a week I did church
on
Sundays does that count when the show
started it got a little bit more
difficult times when I went times when I
didn't I would say I'm Mo I I go to
Catholic Church the most I visited other
churches I've I've visited a Pentecostal
Church um I visited Lutheran Churches I
visited I can't even count I have lived
all over the
world I grew up I I've been to Hindu
churches I've been to I mean I I know
there's a name for them but we went to
like these temples when I lived in or
not lived but I went to India for two
weeks I think they're Hindu I I don't
remember
um I've lived I I I grew up with nannies
from around the world that were all
different Rel religions okay like they
were Christian Catholic Lutheran it
varied now before I keep going guys
please hit the cash app please hit the
venmo we are currently demonetized on
this channel so sending me this stuff
helps okay that's it but anyways
continue
um I also lived
in you know I've been to churches all
around the world and I had this
observation
I don't find that Christian women are
Kinder nicer and more chased than the
general
population I I don't find that the
quality of
wives I is that much higher in the
church now many people will come to me
and say pearl but
Pearl and I saw this this very simpy guy
I I don't understand the simpy these
days usually like men were men and maybe
like in the old days you would go to the
church and men were men but now it's
like the sing the sing is just off the
charts off the
charts um I said I'm sorry I don't see a
difference in the kindness Chastity and
selflessness of Christian women versus
non-Christian women women are women
don't shoot the messenger
now is this wrong am I not allowed to
say that to say my
experience in
churches not one church not two churches
not three not four not five are
Christian
women really of of that much higher
quality now have I had Christian women
do very nice things for me yes yes I
have met some amazing Christian wives
and
mothers but I wouldn't say that they
were that much higher quality than when
I just go play volleyball go on the
street or just hang out with regular
people and so this caused a reaction and
I and I've noticed that whenever I say
things that are are somewhat true and
kind of hurt people's
feelings I've just noticed that
they tend to go to these arguments first
they attack my faith they say pearl is
not real Christian if she was a real
Christian she would know that we are
amazing and awesome and
special okay then I say what they say
what church do you go to your church is
just the
worst and I think to myself so if I go
to your church I'll find no single women
over
25 no divorces no ex hos no pastors
screwing the pre the congregation okay
did you know 50% of pastors have
admitted to having an affair or an
emotional
affair I didn't create the world that I
live
in okay um in the general population 5%
of couples wait till marriage
I mean did I did I create
this this is the world I was born into
like what did I
do and if you go to if you go to
churches um what you see
often and I could say this because I I
grew up in the Catholic
church and it's not just the Catholic
church it's across the
board controlling
wives you you see all these Bible verses
about Mutual
submission um I can only submit to my
husband when he follows
God and then she just determines when he
follows
God I I saw extreme simpery oh my gosh I
have never seen higher simpery than in
the
church you know I would see
guys one I I would see these women
talking about being ex hes and I would
just think to myself isn't that
embarrassing for your husband is that
isn't that kind of
inappropriate like to say that in front
of the
whole congregation okay is that am I am
I crazy for saying this
okay second thing okay we have a super
chat I'm gonna I'm gonna stop the show
for a
second thank you Rodriguez thank you
very much thank you very much on top of
that I would see the
pedestalize telling women that they're
more special more important and more
amazing than they are I never heard them
say men are the prize and you need to
earn a husband I heard that the men
needed to earn
you that's what I
heard is this
incorrect is this wrong you know I I
would hear you know if there was ever a
girl that slept around or anything it
would be that the men used
her
huh what are you guys talking about
maybe she used
them a and no matter where I would go it
would just be a lack of accountability
on the women I never heard sermons or
uh men preaching about you know God can
forgive your sins
ladies but men don't have
to I never heard um sermons about how it
was wrong to not sleep with your husband
I never heard sermons about how you know
I would always hear about how
cornography is wrong and
how you know
um
what was it cor I'm saying cornography
you get it um
cornography and you know cheating men
cheating is wrong but I would never
really hear sermons about
modesty um
now is this
incorrect is Pearl just making this up
oh but Pearl it's just a few just a few
churches now we're starting to see even
in the Catholic Church they're now
starting to bless gay couples you're
starting to see pride Flags you're
starting to
see um I remember I was in a church
during the BLM
stuff they started talking about that in
church I mean am am I crazy is this just
pearls just making this
up um and I'm going to keep going okay
pastor's daughters
Catholic school girls born again virgins
female
pastors what do you think of when you
hear these phrases why is the reputation
so bad am I just making this up because
according to you know apparently I just
haven't been in enough churches and it's
really interesting because it always is
they tell me about their special church
that generally has all the same things
that all the other Church churches have
I don't go to church enough
apparently
and yeah that that's kind of what they
what they go
to now what do I think about forgiveness
and
Redemption God can forgive you I totally
think that yes but what they forget to
talk about is men do not have
to men don't have to forgive
you most women today are not going to
get a happy
ending they're
not I mean guys let's let's break down
the numbers here let's break down these
numbers okay half of marriages and half
of women between the ages of 25 and 45
are predicted to be single and
childless this is not me just coming to
you trying to live in a Doomer
World these are Bankers guys that have
no no skin in the game this is from
Morgan
Stanley this is what they're predicting
half of women will not have
kids and they will not have
children so half of women no happy
ending there the other half of
women that do get married half will
divorce
okay about a order of marriages are
sexless you add those in
there and these divorce stats don't
include the people in their 60s and 70s
that will divorce or are
separated guys the future is not bright
it's really not when it comes to
marriage and
relationships now this is not about my
moral beliefs so many times I see
Christian like you know this sovereign
bro guy he's out here preaching about
telling everybody to take the Christ
pill and then he's saying that he's
sleeping with these girls in the last
week I mean this guy and I I don't
really know what his stick is but or in
the last couple of
months I mean it's like take what do
they say take the speck out of your own
eye when all the time there's a plank in
your own eye you hypocrite first take
the plank out of your own eye then you
will see clearly to remove the speck
from your brothers you know that
one you know and and that's my thing
with the churches if churches
want the general population to take the
Christ pill if this is what they want
you guys got to fix up your churches
before coming to everyone else because
you know when we go to a church we
expect to see a higher quality we expect
to see you know no single
mothers um you tell tell the single moms
to get back with their baby
daddy their ex-husband whoever it is or
remarry but more importantly get back
with your ex it's like we go to church
and expect a higher standard a higher
quality I've lived around the world I've
lived in Germany I've lived in England
I've lived in the US I grew up with
nannies from around the like my God I
think I've had a more International life
than any of these people criticizing
me and I could say it's consistent it's
not just one
Church you know um I went to I went to a
town and this was a small town in I
don't know Northern I don't want to say
where but because I I don't want to give
anything away but it it was a small town
middle of nowhere I'll say that and this
guy did the thing he married a Christian
virgin woman and do you know what his
words to me were do you know what he
told
me the church is making my wife worse
she gets in these women's group groups
and she's moral quarrelsome she's
like I I can't remember his exact
wording
but you know it's making my my wife
worse so so many times go and blame
these these red pill guys the they are
the scapegoat they are the guys that
really are just are just trying to
survive they're trying to make the best
of their life they're not going to live
forever and what I'll hear from the take
the Christ pill guys is all here you
can't submit to
feminism and I just thought what does
that
mean what what is if you
one most people aren't that religious so
they're going out and telling everybody
you must be religious while doing the
exact same thing they're preaching not
to
do and not fixing the church first
that's my argument if you want people to
take the take the Christ pill I'm not
saying it's a bad idea I wouldn't bet on
it I don't think that it'll
happen but
don't you think you should fix your
church get rid of the female
pastors get rid of you know tell the
women that you know God can forgive you
men
won't you know and the first time I
heard Kevin Samuels talk about and I'm
going to show you guys this clip talk
about the
church or church women I think it was it
he put to words something I didn't know
how to
verbalize
and it was just like the controlling
nature of women in the church women are
not of higher quality in the churches
and you guys could shoot the messenger
you can come at
me but a lot of the women are just going
to church to look good to their friends
that's
it that's it so my thing is fix the
churches and then and maybe take away
power from the women you know maybe get
women out of leadership
maybe get rid of these female
pastors
maybe get rid of I don't know
the sorry I can hear this doorbell
ringing you know get rid of the the
female
pastors like get get rid of these
women's groups where all women do is go
[__] about their husbands you know I
it's like I was in a church and and this
guy said he wanted more kids but his
wife
didn't so I thought to myself why the
hell is she in
control like that should be his choice
not hers this isn't a oneoff this isn't
an occasional thing there is a reason
that pastors daughters have a reputation
Catholic school girls Church women I
mean guys are starting to avoid this
stuff um hold on I'm going to find find
a I thought I had this up earlier but I
didn't and you guys will blame me
for do
what okay why do and that's my question
to you it why is this oh
[__] why is this the reputation is this
on twox I twox it sometimes okay no so
he's talking about women to avoid
I'm doing I'm leading she's going to
follow there can't be two captains pick
your poison if you pick equality you'll
die slow death She's a big time church
girl I'm a Christian I was born and
raised in the church I attend regularly
but BigTime Church girls tend to come
with Big Time Church problems there's no
more hypocrisy in dating than in the
church because unless she's a big- Time
church girl and a virgin you're already
going to have issues often times Big
Time Church girls try to use the Bible
as a weapon against the men that they
date to hold you biblically accountable
for everything that says a man should be
but yet not hold themselves biblically
morally or ethically accountable to
anything that it says a woman should be
they'll tend to take scriptures out of
context use biblical stories for their
own selfish and manipulative ends and
hit you in a place to where you really
can't defend your spirituality that is
the height of manipulative decep bad
behavior I don't roll with Big Time
church Bible Thumpers for these primary
reasons if it doesn't suit you move on
but you know the kind of person I'm
talking about she's got lots of single
girlfriends you ever see a pack of
animals roaming a neighborhood
so I didn't make the reputation and
that's the crazy thing so it's
like they blame me for the reputation
they created it's not just me saying
this stuff it's truly not I can't get
this Twitter signed in on here so I got
to pull it up on my
phone
um let's
see thank you for the super chats guys
I'm gonna read them mark needen thank
you very
much um Donald Morris thank you very
much for the super super chat okay
so now what are men to do now now I'd
like to say I do not advise men I think
that men should get advice from other
men I think that's the better way to do
it
um
but I I try to put myself in the men's
shoes if you're a guy let's say you're a
trucker that's one of the number one
employers of men in the United States
Trucking you're a trucker in Central
Missouri I just feel like that's like an
American we're going to go Central
Missouri and you found that women that
make you wait for sex tend to waste your
time and are not attracted to
you what's the logical solution that
they're going to come
to now I'm not saying what to do or what
to not do but I can I can understand why
they get there and what incentive do you
have to join the
church when the reputation of church
women is
lower um than that of normal
women when men send their girls to
church and they get
worse what incentive now I know what you
guys
say God yes yes okay fair enough guys
fair
enough but that argument is not strong
enough to get 90% of people to take the
church
pill and you know that's my question you
know take the church P what's your
plan what what are we gonna
do then the other thing another example
I wanted to
show okay wait oh sorry guys wait hold
on how do you define submission
or how do y'all Define
submission submission is selflessness
instead of selfishness submission is
engagement it's adaptability it's
responsiveness it's emotional safety
security expression it's an art and when
it comes to submission it's mutual but
it's voluntary as well so it's not just
one-sided it's both genders both
Partners equal okay and I love
submission because to me it's in a form
of an art it's somebody who has to give
someone the pieces of them that they
won't give to someone else right and I
hate the fact that Society has
influenced people to believe that
submission is subservience yeah and
slavery and control and manipulation
when it's not it's something that a
person has to be willing to give it's
not
forced I've interviewed over a thousand
women
over a thousand women do you know many
Church women guys I have
interviewed oh Pearl you just you just
interview only fans
model do you know how many Church women
I've
interviewed do you have any
idea gosh so many so many and most of
them when you ask them what submission
is its answers like this
so you know my biggest argument is not
that take the Christ pill is wrong per
se but until you fix your own your own
house till you fix the
churches you are not going to get a lot
of men signing up and men will continue
to leave the church because they are not
appreciated there they are belittled and
they're expected to serve
women and until you guys fix that
you're going to keep seeing men exiting
and the thing is with men when they exit
they just exit
quietly they don't women will make a
fuss they'll cry about it they'll you
know men just kind of they're like all
right I'm
out
and yeah and that's why I don't believe
any of these people are serious because
if they were really serious they would
they would get to fix in the churches
but they don't do that they want to just
lecture everybody and get likes on
social media that's what they want to
do um you
know but let me know what you guys think
maybe I'm wrong you know Pro I'm open to
being wrong um but my to answer the
question can God save modern
women yes yes but men don't have to and
every person is accountable for the
choices that they have made made in
their life so let me know what you guys
think in the comments like the video
thanks for tuning in um I'm getting kind
of I'm trying to get better at these
monologues so you know bear with me
please you know we are demonetized now
guys so please send some super chats
when you have a chance like the video